CONGRESSMAN, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> Gillian: $2400 HERE.
$2400 THERE.
YOU’RE TALKING ABOUT REAL MONEY.
THE PENTAGON IS SET TO MAKE AN
ANNOUNCEMENT, ANTHONY THAT
EXPRESSES CONCERNS THAT NUMBERS
OF THE MILITARY HAVE.
NATIONAL RESPONDENT,
JENNIFER GRIFFIN JOINS US FROM
THE PENTAGON WITH THE DETAILS ON
THE FORTHCOMING ANNOUNCEMENT.
HI, JENNIFER.
>> HI.
FOX HAS EXCLUSIVELY CONTAINED A
NEW DATA FROM AN ONLINE SURVEY
OF MILITARY FAMILIES SAYING
THERE HAS BEEN SOME IMPROVEMENT
ALONG WITH THOSE CONCERNED OF
GETTING THE VACCINE.
NOW 70% OF TROOPS SURVEYED SAY
THEY HAVE GOTTEN THE VACCINE OR
PLAN TO DO SO.
ONLY 39% OF ACTIVE-DUTY SPOUSES
SAY THEY PLAN TO GET VACCINATED,
WHICH COULD BE A PROBLEM AS
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF TROOPS
AND THEIR FAMILIES PLAN TO MOVE
TO NEW BASES THIS SUMMER.
COVID COLLABORATIVE, WHICH
CONDUCTED A SURVEY HAS MADE THE
FOLLOWING RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
PENTAGON OFFERING A CHOICE.
66% OF ACTIVE-DUTY SERVICE
MEMBERS SAY HI’S DULL MY IN TYPE
OF VACCINE, FIRES VERSUS MOTOR
NOT
, GUARANTEEING TIME OFF.
22% REPORTED DIFFICULTY IN
OBTAINING A PERMIT THAT FITS
WITH THEIR SCHEDULE.
30% OF ACTIVE-DUTY SPOUSES
REMAIN UNSURE IF THE VACCINE IS
AVAILABLE TO THEM.
THESE SHOW NEW INCENTIVES FOR
THOSE WHO HAVE BEEN VACCINATED.
NEXT, A FORMER ARMY INFANTRY
OFFICER WHO STARTED A CLOTHING
COMPANY, RANGER UP, EXPLAIN
TROOPS CONCERNS.
>> IF THERE’S A GENERAL LACK OF
TRUST ANY TIME THE GOVERNMENT IS
INVOLVED.
YOU KNOW, WHETHER YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT THE ANTHRAX
VACCINE BACK IN THE DAY THAT
CAUSE PROBLEMS OR ALL OF THESE
THINGS THAT YOU KIND OF COME OF
THE HAS USED AS A GUINEA PIG.
>> THIS FORMER COMBAT VETERAN
JUST GOT HIS SECOND COVID
VACCINE AND IS WORKING HARD TO
CONVINCE OTHER TROOPS AND
VETERANS ABOUT WHY THEY SHOULD